One thing that came up in these stories today
that I really thought was interesting,
and I'd love to get your take on, everybody,
is we're gonna talk about spoilers.
Now I just assumed everyone hates a spoiler.
It turns out some people love them.
The Washington Post reports
that some people wanna know how a TV show ends
before they watch it.
Or they like to read that last page of the book
before they buy it.
Very "When Harry Met Sally."
They say spoilers help them determine
if they wanna invest the time
in a TV show, movie, book.
And for some, knowing the outcome
helps them enjoy the ride even more.
Ross, thoughts?
Well, you know, I don't like to judge anybody.
(Drew laughs)
But something is seriously wrong with you.
(audience laughs)
I don't like you, I don't know you.
I don't wanna know you.
What? Why?
Why would you wanna know how it ends?
Why would you wanna know that Carrie
ended up with Big?
Sorry, if you didn't know.
(audience laughs)
Why would you wanna know that
and not go on the journey of the character?
You need help. I'm sorry, but you do.
(audience laughs)
Okay, show of hands,
who likes spoilers in the audience?
Now listen.
(audience laughs)
You looked so normal to me, sitting there.
I see a woman right here in the front row.
What is your name?
And why did you raise your hand?
My name is Karina,
and when I go to the book store
and pick up a book, I always go to the ending.
If I don't like the ending,
I don't buy the book.
Now listen, you seem normal to me, right?
You do.
(audience laughs)
But don't you wanna go on the journey, dear?
Don't you wanna, you know, find out,
and see what happens?
Yeah, but the ending of the book
tells me whether or not the journey
is going to be worth reading the rest of the book.
You know...
(audience laughs)
And then like, TV series.
Like, if I find out a TV series is being canceled
that I'm watching,
I'm just like, I just drop it.
(audience laughs)
I'm sorry to disappoint you!
Well, you'll be happy to know "Yellowstone"
just got picked up for season five.
I know, season five!
(audience applauds)
I've been binging all weekends.
All weekends.
Thank you for participating!
Thank you, I still don't get you.
But thank you.
(audience laughs)
I love that we can learn from each other.
All right, next up,
do you wanna know what the end of this story is
before I get to it?
(audience laughs)
All right, next up-
Now I kind of wanna try it.
Okay, scroll to the last line.
I'll give you the last line.
Yeah, do it!
Do it, scroll to the end, ready?
Dan, will you go to the end?
Here are the last line.
Instead, why not give the bride a hand?
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Okay, back to the top, let's try this.
We're talking about the wedding term
that some experts say we have to retire.
Anybody ever heard of the term bridezilla?
(audience mutters)
Uh-huh.
Well, Insider reports that term was coined
way back in the 90's,
and it's been thrown about so much,
but it is actually unfair.
Because they say planning a wedding
really is stressful and is emotional,
and we don't need to demonize women
who are just trying to pull together a big day
under a ton of pressure.
Instead, they say,
why not give that bride a hand?
(Drew laughs)
Why not give the bride a hand?
I tell you, I'm in the middle
of planning a wedding right now,
and I am not groomzilla.
Okay?
I was maybe in a moment or two...
Not even in the neighborhood of groomzilla,
but the area code.
Kind of like, a moment of stress.
(audience laughs)
And just yesterday they did a face time,
like, at the venue of where it's gonna be,
and something in my head clicked
and it was all gone.
You know, all the stress was gone.
Really?
Yeah, and I think there should be that moment.
I hope there's that moment for every bride,
every groom out there,
every person who's having a wedding,
where you do get to let go of that.
Because it is so stressful.
And to demonize people who are
just trying to have a moment is wrong.
This one made me feel bad about the term.
I was like, "Yeah, you're right."
Like, if you're really going through it,
and you got a ton of pressure,
and all that stuff,
the last thing you need is someone giving you
a rude nickname that's gonna make you
feel worse about yourself.
Yeah, how about we just don't judge people
who are just trying to express love?
How about that?
Right?
(audience applauds)
We could do that.
I like how everybody likes to do it,
and they should be supported
and not be called some ratty little name for it.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
Yeah, do it your way.